president Trump pummeling his Attorney
General Jeff Sessions yet again today
this comes after the embattled AG pushed
back against Trump's criticism defending
his performance at the DOJ and vowing
not to be influenced by political
considerations chief national
correspondent ed Henry joins us with the
latest on the heated feud what's going
on it
good to see you Jesse you know the war
words and I hear Greg they're bullying
me that's interesting it's really
intensifying because it's not really new
for the president to punch the Attorney
General what's surprising is Jeff
Sessions decided to fire back and may
just be counter punching his way out of
a job
the feud has been getting ugly for some
time with the president tweeting last
year the Attorney General was
beleaguered and then tweeting earlier
this month that sessions was
quote/unquote missing in action on
democratic scandals like the Clinton
email Pro but the spat appeared to
escalate Wednesday the president's
interview with Fox Fox's Ainsley
Earhardt where he didn't just take
another swing at sessions for letting
James Comey and others off the hook he
questioned his manhood sessions listen
to this are very strong in the Justice
Department
I put an attorney general that never
took control of the Justice Department
Jeff Sessions never took control of the
Justice Department he took the job and
then he said I'm going to recuse myself
I said what kind of a man is this now
sessions usually ignores those punches
but yesterday decided to try and brush
the president back with a statement
claiming he took control of justice on
day one and adding quote while I am
Attorney General the actions of the
Department of Justice will not be
improperly influenced by political
considerations this afternoon
former session spokesman Eden Pryor told
me the Attorney General responded this
time because the president's words were
more powerful on camera rather than just
tweets and I pressed him on answering
the president's complaint about why his
friends are facing indictments and
criminal charges while on the Democratic
side the Justice Department appears to
be laying off under this Department of
Justice they are not going to talk about
ongoing investigations publicly or in
any other way so we don't know what
they're investigating what they're
looking at beyond that there needs to be
enough evidence for a jury to for a
grand jury to indict somebody now
Republican Lindsey Graham says that
session should not be ousted before the
midterms when you've got
Brett Cavanaugh's nomination other
matters to deal with but Graham said
change may be coming after the midterms
and the president a few hours ago
tweeted out reaction accession
statements saying Jeff that's great that
all of a sudden you don't want political
considerations go after some of the
Democratic scandals that's the
president's message all right thanks
have a great weekend you too all right
well it looks like he's just trying to
browbeat the Attorney General into
resigning
I hope accessions is getting the message
so uh they're like Ross and Rachel on
friends they fight they break up but you
know what I really think they belong
together
because I think there's some chemistry
they fight in public which makes it
uncomfortable for all of us and god help
you if you take a side cuz then they'll
both turn against you that happens
whenever a couple fights here's my
problem with this is that I'm not a fan
of office politics my concern is that
you know it's a distraction from serious
matters we just saw an Isis audio
released and in which it's like maybe
al-baghdadi might not be dead talking
about current events
so we're obsessing over parlor intrigue
and payoffs to porn stars and our
enemies are reloading they work 24/7
while we sit and we get distracted and
they're waiting for the right time our
media is distracted we're kind of
distracted we're complacent and we're
complacent in large part because
President Trump and our military made
Isis feel like a distant memory so
they're not around anymore so we're we
can have fun with this stuff but I get
I'm a little worried because I'm a
neurotic freak here here yes right Katie
I do understand the president's
frustration with his Attorney General
and he explained it pretty specifically
here he says deleted Clinton emails
Comey lives and leaks mulher conflicts
mccabe Strock Page Bruce and Nellie or
FISA abuse Kris Steele and the dossier
the Clinton Foundation surveillance
devolution you get you get his
frustration because it looks like he's
being railroaded by all these
investigations yet on the other hand his
political enemies who he believes have
done a lot of wrong things are getting
off scot-free
well I think it's frustrating from
administration to administration when
you see scandal happen in the Obama
administration for example typically
when a new administration comes in the
next DOJ kind of closes the door
what happened and tries to move on now
whether that's because they don't want
to look into that because they may have
their own problems with their own is one
question but politically this is not a
good situation for the president it's
going to be very difficult to confirm
someone who's as conservative as Jeff
Sessions on these issues and when it
comes to what sessions said when he
fought back against what the president
said he focused on other issues outside
of what the president's complaining
about I've been working on violent crime
I've been working on terrorism I've been
working on your one huge campaign issue
which is illegal immigration so if you
don't want someone who's going to be
doing all those things good luck because
it's gonna be very difficult to find
someone who's willing to go to the mat
on those issues at the Justice
Department there was a silver lining
though yes there was a silver lining
there's you know there's a good picture
of you in between yeah yeah I'm sitting
between the two gentlemen but I will
tell you the silver lining that I saw in
this was when Jeff Sessions spokesperson
said they're investigating things that
we're not going to know about so I hope
they're going after McKay Beck I can't
ride off in the sunset they should be
going after struck who got fired they
should be going after Lisa page what
they did was a prehensile it's horrible
they should be going after Bruce or over
there all the fusions in the foundation
of course Clinton Foundation so I'm
hoping that they are doing their job and
and really we shouldn't know about it if
they are as well as far as abuse but as
I said yesterday one I think if sessions
gets too involved in doing the
president's bidding or going after some
of the president's political enemies
regardless or not whether they did
corrupt things it's going to create the
appearance of obstruction of justice
because you have this ongoing Muller
investigation so he feels like he's in a
bind probably you're a wise man too
thank you in keeping with that laundry
list that you had before it sounds like
you're you know lock her up lock her up
this is a Trump rally
I don't want it locked up I wanted to
run again yes
this is first of all all the things that
you listed have been investigated all
the people who know me and all those
people oh I see and this the the FBI now
is not run by a Republican the head of
the Justice Department not a Republican
the deputy turned out not a Republican
these are Republicans and you guys are
attacking your own it's hard to believe
that Republicans trumpian or is that how
you say uh Trump you say what you want
okay unless you're a trumpeter Trump
acolyte sure then you can't you're not
allowed in the club in him what about
the politics of this Gregg so if he does
cut sessions loose before the midterms
it creates an impossible scenario to
reconfirm but let's just say they keep
the Senate and so they have the majority
I could see him replacing sessions in
December and having them be confirmed or
the new person confirmed in January I
don't know I get it
I can't who knows who knows I don't know
if he stays there he goes
I kind of like session seems like a nice
guy met him once at dinner with nice
sooo nice maybe but you know there's
never been a more transparent
administration he castigates his staff
publicly which is unusual but but it's
his the least deceptive president I've
ever seen we know about all this stuff
the interesting part about this story
none of this ever would have happened if
Trump didn't win and we now we know that
Trump wasn't supposed to win and so he
set up all sorts of punishment from all
sides you know and it's like and you
have to have chef if Hillary had one
would you've seen the same kind of
investigations about her corruption the
dossier story is way way WAY worse than
anything Trump's don't I mean come on
more worse than a meetings craziness
stay away from the conspiracies I'll say
that ok let's start if there is someone
that President Trump has in mind to
replace Attorney General Sessions it
would have to be someone who would agree
to fire Muller right it would have to be
someone who is sure agree to attack the
Democrats so it would be totally a
political move our law enforcement our
top
law enforcement organization the Justice
from United States would be totally
politicized like Eric Holder in the law
enforcement community in this country to
an extent that I think we've never aired
colder undermined this 5149 Republican
majority in the Senate Katie I don't
think given what Susan Collins said
today what John Cornyn said today that
there's any agree with that but there's
any chance that the Senate would confirm
a new action
I actually agree maybe right now but you
know the man who's in charge of the
Senate Judiciary Committee chuck
Grassley last year was saying we're good
not we don't have time in the docket to
deal with this right now but he did open
the door to having some time maybe later
on in the year and that's a big question
I do want to say though when you know I
covered by administration scandals and
nobody was ever fired for anything so
the idea that Peter shock did get fired
but Andrew McCabe got fired and it may
have taken a little longer but there
because of the bureaucracy and the rules
around labor laws in the federal
government it there is a process they
have to go through I do think it
actually says a lot about being able to
get those guys fired and I think that
that Christopher ray should get credit
for that thank you and in the commercial
break Pam is going to tell us the
conversation the president had across
from her with jeff Sessions might and it
better be good